and Carly still joins a party now with
the star who definitely knows how to
dazzle in a bikini Mariah Carey and
Carly the exclusive look that you got
into movies world of meetings beyond
well Cameron you know they say the key
to a happy romance is separate bathrooms
yes the course well in the case of Mimi
and her man James it is his and hers
yachts oh yes this is the lifestyles of
the rich and fabulous darling
ciao Mariah yeah Bella this is
unbelievable Wow a nice is like one of
my favorite places ever we're on a
stunning yacht the cap rates gorgeous
you and James have his and hers yachts
that is the most fabulous thing I have
ever seen in my life how important is it
to have his or her yachts I think it's
important of his in her everything yup
his and hers yachts the his is the
Arctic P the seventh largest privately
owned vessel in the world
it belongs to Mariah's fiance Australian
billionaire James Packer the hers a
chartered 16 crew luxury liner that
she's calling home for the summer
they're anchored together off the coast
of Italy and I got an exclusive tour I
like your shoes oh he's a merciless
merci one there's your cribs moment
we're here in this gorgeous bar I love
that there's a bar on boat oh why are
you trying to paint it that way
don't bring it that way there's a bar
here in the middle of the seating area
which I like because I've got a
lightness of this room is very feminine
is kind of cool
the master suite with its opulent bath
it's just one of six staterooms there
are two bars a jacuzzi a gym a library
and plenty of seating areas on the 192
foot Capri there's also a private chef
and a tender to ferry Mariah and her
twins Munro and Moroccan over to James's
digs where all the parties happens it's
a total bargain at a reported three
hundred and forty thousand dollars a
week Oh
plus expenses which include the forty
thousand dollars a week in fuel alone I
know your kids are on the boat what if
they enjoyed the moans they love
swimming in the water they're amazing
swimmers Arctic pee has an epic flight
in it which I wanted to go under I went
on a slide
did you yeah we're gonna say uh officer
that it was good I don't know if I'm
doing it again but it was good I love
the Instagram posts of you singing to
the weekend at Leonardo DiCaprio all
that was the best that was so much fun
cuz I love him I'd love to see you guys
collaborate I would love to see this - I
love you - give it up in italiano
they're excited hi lambs yes we were
back in the studio working on a new
project
Mariah isn't totally on vacation she's
updating her Caesars Palace residency in
Las Vegas and working on a new album
with longtime collaborator Jermaine
Dupri taking a ferry to the studio an
hour away in Naples every night but when
it comes to her relationship with James
she says all is smooth sailing how do
you guys make that work most boys you
know cuz I you know I want you to roll
with their schedule but like I said he's
very cool very understanding and so like
yeah I get it when he has to do
yes things that he has to do he candies
understands mine it's just like if I'm
writing a song four o'clock in the
morning I'm not going to like go up
there blasting music and well I did that
it wasn't your Sam better that you're
deaf whatever I'm talking too much
how are you planning like a wedding
during all of this first off by the way
you've got arctic pain you've got
Captain I just just get him to marry you
guys no big deal that's an interesting
thought yeah but I don't know about this
I'll give you some more hints as the
time goes on she just keeps teasing it
but good try good try yeah I know you
got a lot more info from Mariah
certainly did I got the answer to the
one question every woman wants to know
how does Mariah keep her body looking so
incredible especially on vacation well
you'll hear her secret tomorrow and no
cameras no you're thinking it's not
spangle unlike the two piers I'm wearing
right now come on